I genuinely hope Ben is not buying any  of this nope he definitely did it the  dreaded two-on-one date was at the  center of this week's bachelor episode  and it was Olivia versus Emily  I'm sure she's being her typical Olivia  just we ragging about herself Olivia  Olivia Olivia I'm very grounded very  like in tune with my body like I just  I'm really strong  oh she was definitely being typical  Olivia but things got really deep just  deep intellectual things are just my jam  do bad Olivia is it Ben's jam the  reality Stargate but rose to Emily over  the 23 year old news anchor how do you  date this many women that you have  feelings for and keep everybody happy  does anybody know judging by the promo  for next week's tear-filled episode Ben  hasn't quite figured out the answer